David I've got to say Anish giri it
feels like the chess gods are on his
side today I especially after winning
that last game that really surprising
Checkmate in The Rook end game that we
saw and Levon aronian just um it's been
a difficult few days for him and uh
especially with black it's not going to
be easy he probably needs to win not
just this game but most of his games
tomorrow
um if not all of them just have a chance
to qualify
the game has started where five moves
into it how are we seeing some great
opening stuff from Anish potentially
it's still early days this is a branch
of the reti opening
where white is happy to let the black
Pawns in the center Advance quite far
but uh White will try to counter-attack
a bit later this is similar to something
we saw yesterday in or two days ago
sorry in a game between Hans Neiman and
Vincent climber but uh Gary's clearly
done his homework this is a rare night
jump as far as I know
and uh I guess the idea is to just clamp
down on this Square White Knight it's
not actually that easy to get rid of
and the trade of minor pieces if it does
happen that tends to favor white who's a
bit cramped who has a bit less space and
there we see Levon Orion's shoulder I
was wondering what that was
he loves his basketball jerseys yeah and
uh it's probably it's probably one of
the best dressed guys out there like Lev
because he's got loads of cool shirts as
well charismatic style right definitely
definitely yeah so it's very colorful I
wouldn't say unnecessarily the best
dress like as in like sharp not sharp
but fun fun yeah
yeah I I like it definitely
meanwhile both King's castling
I'm slightly surprised by Ennis Geary's
opening Choice it feels like again the
type of opening you choose when you want
to win at all costs or you have to win
but with this last Pawn push he's going
to get a solid position we'll see a
trade of Pawns in the center of the
board and white won't have any more
development problems yeah yeah it's all
going to look pretty balanced to be
honest but maybe Gary's just saying to
Iranian you need to beat me so I'm gonna
try and trade off a set of Pawns maybe
trade off some pieces and you are the
one who has to take risks
think about this position for either
side Simon Ivanka
yeah I mean well I was just thinking the
last time I can remember when Iranian
has he never not qualified I mean every
every one of these events I've
commentated on he seems to always
qualify quite comfortably so it's quite
big quite a big turnaround that you know
that he's struggling this time I like
White's position going back to the chest
just because the harmony of the pieces
all you have to do is look at pawns and
pieces and the pawn structure is fairly
even but the pieces Black's got some
pieces at home he's got his Knight
blocking pieces in and White's pieces
are free the Rooks are already connected
so it must be just a very nice avant-ish
away and I expect white will move in the
center because when you've got better
piece Harmony you want to try to
translate that into something tangible
and to do that often you want to open up
the position and I I think white will
will probably be aiming to open up the
position here to to make those pieces
even better so it just seems really nice
to watch you the more I look at it
really nice very easy to play and here
he goes he's putting his behind the pawn
getting ready to push that one and
everything's looking yeah perfect yeah
I'm slightly surprised he didn't start
with your move Simon by pushing the pawn
first because I'm not sure whether it's
good or not but black does have the
option to stop this Pawn push now to
clamp down on this square and then right
White's Rook looks at least a slightly
bit silly yeah uh on this square if the
central file isn't going to become open
then what's the Rook actually doing here
do you think one of the weaknesses of a
niche game is just a bit hesitant at
times I mean it's a fantastic play but
he's just missing like one percent like
it seems at times to become potentially
the world champion you know um and here
you see that yeah you're totally right
David and uh now he cut now he's always
got this in actual fat backwards Pawn
the Pawn's always bad I totally missed
this idea from black maybe you Niche did
as well but but I mean is it such a big
disaster yeah okay the white Rook is
misplaced but on the other hand you know
white pieces have a lot of good
potential the bishop the light Square
Bishop has is a beautiful diagonal to
look at and one fine day if a knight
could reach the D5 Square
then whoa it's uh it's a post yeah it
takes a while though one two three four
maybe yeah yeah I thought he could have
started that Journey even going the
other way as well with the night last
movement but uh it just seems that you
know it's got a little bit more complex
now and Anish would I think rather have
had a very safe Advantage I think anyone
would have uh to be honest in this
position then
giving himself a bit of a structural
weakness it's not you know I still like
white but yeah it's called a backwards
Pawn White's Pawn in the middle of the
board this is what you call a backwards
Pawn because it can never move because
it always get captured and is on a half
open file if you look at the lines in
front of it black is always attacking
that pawn or can attack it with a rook
or a queen a straight line piece
um so that's that's the sort of
long-term problems that Anish has given
himself
I mean while the black Rook moves uh it
was on this diagonal that Ivanka
highlighted so I guess levonne aruna's
next move Flex Next plan at least no
matter what white does is to push this
Pawn forward and develop his Bishop
perhaps to this diagonal so it's very
balanced now and long term Black's doing
well as you mentioned with this uh
backward Pawn for white but it's just
about whether Anish Gary can whip up
anything short term in this position
it's not his style necessarily to create
he wants to kind of fixate on one
long-term weakness and then pound away
at it but right now he needs to be the
creative one and maybe that involves
re-routing the Knight
there's a few ways to do it maybe back
and then forward but uh yeah I just
don't like his decision at all and I
think he rushed slightly he was up at 16
minutes when he made that Rook move
allowing black this bind these two pawns
White had some very tempting moves uh
earlier and
I don't know it just feels like he's
rushing through the critical moments but
okay there will be of course uh
decisions ahead
and uh yeah let's go back to the players
because this one will take a slower
maneuvering uh turn right now
the next phase of the game is just going
to be both pieces uh both sides both
sets of pieces trying to find good
squares yeah and talking about uh
looking at the Players uh we see the
bishop Retreat well Maritza sends us
chess sketch that they've drawn this is
not my best chess picture but one of my
favorite sketches can you guess who
it's our Magnus
and glasses give it away right yeah yeah
it's the glasses yes really impressive
sketch it is very impressive I like it
it's like a photo almost it does yeah
yeah super realistic they well yeah not
quite but they called it don't you yeah
and if you two want to send in your
pictures your selfies your thoughts your
questions then you can always tweet us
using the hashtag chess Champs
yeah lots of art uh theme of the show
today yeah yeah definitely inspired by
that uh Carlson A1 shook game maybe kind
of artistic by Yvonne stroke there
yeah
me while black just defending his
stronghold White's ganging up all his
pieces against black Central eporn but
looks quite straightforward to defend
at the moment okay interesting White's
gonna double up both Rooks on the e-file
the reason I'm not a big fan of the way
White's played this is just sort of long
term now uh previously Anish had the
long-term advantages because he could
have uh you know pushed in the center
but now long term wise he's got the
worst Pawn structure so uh that you know
so he has to be a little bit careful I
mean again his position is absolutely
fine but just long term he's made it a
little bit tricky but he didn't need to
so
yeah I guess uh at least he's got some
active plans in mind yeah um so just uh
if we jump in I'm assuming black
I mean he has a bunch of choices here
but I'm assuming he plays the most
natural move the move he's been
preparing just developing his Bishop to
the long diagonal white will slide
across putting pressure on this E Pawn
it's actually attacked let me count four
times now by White's Knight Rook bishop
and Rook they're all peering down at
this
Central Pawn black might have to defend
it it's only defended three times defend
it for a fourth time and
guess anisha's idea is to start offering
favorable exchanges Black's Bishop now
Black's dark squared Bishop is the worst
piece on the board it's completely
locked in behind its wall of Pawns so
you want to trade off every piece other
than this bishop so for example you
could start by moving the Knight out the
way trading the Bishops off these light
squared Bishops you want to leave this
one remember next if you can somehow
maybe bring the queen across join an
attack with the white knight that looks
good if you could ideally trade off
these Knights as well you'll leave your
opponent with that terrible Bishop
and Ivanka yeah no I I think this
position is looks good and there we see
the Rooks lined up
um one kind of question I had in this
position is uh is white threatening to
break out
oh in the center yeah interesting so for
example after a pull push can white
break in the center with the idea that
if there's a pawn capture it takes it
with a bishop and uh now this Pawn is
pinned and the Central File if there's a
capture or it takes a rook winning the
black queen and
let's do a quick count it's Queen for
rook and Bishop white has a big material
advantage
is possible I guess there's not it's not
necessary to capture the second time for
black so black will maintain this pin
and I don't know just develop the queen
maybe or bring the bishop here to trade
off
it's not clear who this exchange helps
but I guess White's got rid of the
backward Pawn
so this would make some sense maybe this
is what's making Levon aronian hesitate
the idea of this Pawn stepping forward
yeah really interesting
that's a good move to half on the radar
definitely
could pawns can have a break forward
then often it changes the whole nature
of the position and often favorably as
well yeah
we do see the bars have started moving
and the other games are in round 12.
Prague is it looking bad for him against
Hans Neiman in this game the bar has now
uh shut up for the American player Iman
sarich as well the bar to all the way
over to his side against David Navarro
Liam
is it looking good for him against the
evanchook and Duda the bar all the way
over to his side against adibon gelfand
and Carlson is playing that's an
interesting battle between the legend
gal fund and the world number one Magnus
Carlsen Eric icy on fire in this
tournament the bar all the way over to
his side against Christopher you
still in the middle between whiteochik
and kymer and roughly in the middle in
the game we are following Anish giri and
the vulneronian
yeah
everywhere yeah this is kind of the
Mover and Shake around where they just
position themselves and tomorrow it's
just they'll all know what is required
and uh yeah even the players who are
struggling they want to keep their fate
in their own hands that's why I love on
a running I guess needs to win because
if he loses I think that's nothing done
for the tournament and it wasn't the
final round yesterday where all games
ended up with a winner will we see the
same today that would be cool
would be very cool meanwhile the
variation we showed has appeared on the
board Black's Queen meanwhile has just
slightly improved herself and White's
Queen
this is a tripling of pieces the two
white Rooks and the White Queen lined up
on the e-file kind of cool that it's a
bit like the alakyne's gun right
um I think that's when you have the
queen at the back
um it was first by played by alakyne and
I can never pronounce his name correctly
is it aliakin is it alakyne the English
pronunciation is alakyne so where
someone will probably correct me there I
don't know but it's a yeah he first
played it in a couple of games and uh
it's a yeah can't get more power than
that on a on a file yeah so normally as
you say Simon for example you want this
formation yeah the alicorn's gun yeah so
this way around this is what you
normally want the queen supports from
behind but yeah it looks very powerful
either way and uh you know Gary's idea I
guess is to re-look at the queen to this
side of the board though
uh he wants to go for this black king
which lacks Defenders right now and of
course the White Knight is ready to jump
into F5 which is always a signal to
attack yeah to go forward and uh we
mustn't also forget that because the
Rooks are kind of eyeing up their
counterparts
black white could be also threatening on
top of all this is to push the F Pawn
forward and destabilize the center
oh he's pushing those Pawns of anchor I
know I know I know it's a good idea
though yeah I'm just thinking as a bonus
throw that in you know I think wise
position looks very good yeah for
example if black pushes a pawn then you
could definitely
nice
bit of course white would win a rook
finally
begun
fires off and uh wins so yeah right now
it's difficult for black to even move he
decides okay to get out of the eye line
of these three pieces
and he moves his Rook out the way a bit
of a weird one I guess he wants to
potentially push his Pawn forward and at
least there's no pin in the center
it's wrong somehow gotta be very careful
of the black king I mean queen and
Knight coordinates so well together and
maybe this is uh why aronians or just
bringing his pieces around his King he'd
probably have to tuck his King in the
corner as well soon but it looks very
risky you know the Knight and queen can
start
um creating some Frets maybe maybe
combined with that mood that Ivanka said
as well you know trying to open up the
the you know the board with a pawn uh
Pawn lever as well looks uh yeah I I
like it for white I mean I love
attacking and you're attacking so safely
yeah as you mentioned Simon big threat
uh on the board this is a night check
and a fork uh Black's Pawn is not
guarding that square because it is
pinned and
yeah this looks really scary yeah um I
would be terrified of everything
collapsing here for black
um also I guess on your radar would be
this one Simon Just certainly some
points uh yeah at some point using it as
a battering ram yeah
bring it all the way up and also maybe
trying to get the white Brook over
um we've mentioned having three
attacking pieces and you can potentially
think about doing that as well so it
seems like all the play is in White's
favor maybe the other Rook as well at
some point but yeah I mean there's many
ideas that white can think of here
Knight and queen uh very nice but if
black can kick the back black will be
okay as well so yeah
Knight does jump in the King has to move
out the way
I like I like the Harry push funnily
enough
surprising really your style Simon but
can black start pushing the Knight away
that that's the real question if you can
then Black's also fine yeah I mean I
guess firstly the Knight can park itself
on the edge of the board but on a quite
nice attacking Square secondly maybe now
you can exchange off and now that this
diagonal has been slightly weakened by
Black's last Pawn push
maybe ivanka's move maybe this idea yeah
yeah yeah yeah
absolutely David put it on the board put
it on the board put it on the board
David
I like it it deserves to go on the board
there exactly now look at the bishop I
know that's one strong Bishop is it
still called a fiancate old Bishop on
this Square well that's a good question
Kaya does it have to be on that uh it
have to be back here on B2 yeah no idea
actually the history
questions
I don't know it deserves to be called a
theme keto okay yeah yeah I mean this is
just as strong as anything Bishop yeah
it's on its longest diagonal definitely
this is us all the prayers in the world
this bishop it's a monster Bishop yeah
so this is the type of thing that could
happen uh in the current position we're
expecting white to push one of his pawns
uh or maybe this one but uh we're coming
around to liking this one first pushing
it forward
simply stabilize the black king position
okay he chooses the other one first
makes sense as well the more aggressive
move actually um because you are at
least starting conflict immediately
against Black's Pawn there and uh and
the point is really if black takes that
pawn you're just opening up the white
Rooks and this should spell disaster
surely I mean well I don't know I
wouldn't I would not even think about
taking that pawn maybe it's playable but
I would be amazed if there's not
something horrible here for black I mean
a trade of pieces and maybe black can
block with his bishop or knight uh on
this yeah on this back rank I'm not sure
which piece is better but uh it's signed
by a thread so defensive isn't it this
this way of playing so you don't you
don't want to play this and white can
win the pawn back here anyway exactly it
says no you don't want to do this
definitely not so I I like this I like
this
is playing good proactive aggressive
moves yeah so good game actually from
nisha's a little bit pessimistic or uh
you know about his moves earlier he's
turned it around yeah yeah he's got
momentum on his side he's playing Super
quickly and left on aronian
Blitz that game against Neiman earlier
uh and ended up falling to defeat
maybe learning his lesson is slowing
down slightly but uh
I mean it's just so hard now to even
find a move for black if you don't want
to allow White's Rooks in
what do you do he Retreats his Bishop
this is yeah a sad move to play as well
but uh maybe necessary just over
protecting some important squares
well the real question is now can you
just win that pawn I mean uh again when
if you if you guys at home are looking
at you know how can I improve
in the middle game lots of people
struggle if you get a position where
there's conflict
the pawns are ready to capture each
other always think about what happens if
you capture first look at the most
forcing moves first work them out if
they work you don't even need to look at
other moves
um do you believe in that analogy like
if you see if you see a strong move slow
down try to find a better move I don't
always agree with that I'm like if I see
a strong move I'm just going to play I
can't be bothered to find a better move
you know sometimes I will look a little
bit but you don't always need to you can
just play the strong move
what I try and do is I try to stick to I
say try because it's actually quite
difficult for me you stick to the CCT
rule you know kind of text captures
threats and and I sometimes I add Pawn
breaks and then I try to run through
that list just in case anything escapes
my radar do you do that consciously
because I I think I don't I don't know
anyone who would go for that list
consciously it's more of a subconscious
thing I guess right or I mean I never
used to but I've done it a lot in later
years just uh because I get in time
trouble so much and for example if I
only have five minutes left and it's a
position where there's four tempting
moves I'll think okay what order should
I really look in then I'll just force
myself but it's it's hard to talk to
yourself too much I guess during the
game but I'll be like okay I have to
look at the checks just in case yeah if
those don't work then the threats or
then the capture is then the threats but
yeah it's uh I think the more you
practice it the less you actually need
to tell yourself right it just happens
automatically as it does with the top
players in the world yeah yes someone
who I noticed did it like on a
subconscious basis was uh Judith poga
yeah whenever she analyzes it's always
like the checks captures the threats
yeah and it's very impressive because
I'm not at that stage actually why I can
do it subconsciously right okay so my
mind is always a little bit of a muddle
yeah that's why everyone trains it's
always nice to perfect these uh these
skills which I mean even the top players
they they have to work on in order to
maintain and uh okay in the process Gary
has one upon as Simon mentioned why look
for better moves when you can just win a
pawn
but uh at the same time it just feels
like Gary He's again trying to play the
long term just materialistic way just
get the long-term Advantage thing grind
it out when he could have been attacking
he could have been uh just fearlessly
going for that black king in the other
variations that we showed
so he's got the advantage plus one says
the computer one extra Pawn on the board
but what next that backward deep one
maybe that's the problem Simon uh right
now
yeah you called earlier yeah and again
we talked about this Pawn that Black's
Rook has lined up against just imagine
that white Pawn moving two squares
forwards white be completely winning and
this is why Pawn structure is so
important and I always say you know
there's two things in chess Pawn
structure is like your skeleton you've
got to have a good skeleton uh you know
a two to function properly and pieces
are like your organs so you've got to
make sure both of them are are doing a
good job and try to make your skeleton
as good as possible I mean that pawns a
bit like a bit of a you know hunch got a
bit of a back problem there without
pulling in the middle if you could move
it two square swords you'd be you'd be
standing fine uh but I do like White's
pieces saying that I mean White's pieces
still to my eyes
seem quite fantastic the organs pumping
very well there on the open lines and uh
you know maybe there's a bit of
maneuvering to do with them but white
has the chance it's all the chances are
still interesting game and looks like we
have a bunch of interesting games here
in round 12. the bar is all the way uh
well okay it's gone a little bit down
but it's been way up for Hans Neiman
against pregnant under these two
teenagers and there's only one game in
history that I can
remember and that is the the Carlson
Niemann game from yesterday and I
actually did check that game and it is
that opening in that game I guess it's a
very normal opening but could it be
Prague with the white piece is kind of
trying to put neem on a little bit off
yeah keep that opening do D4 Knight F6
C4 you resign now but uh no uh I mean
even I was just looking at that game of
briefly another great opening it seems
like his opening preparation is really
hitting another level nah um in general
Neiman just destroyed aronian out the
opening uh big advantage against Prague
out the opening but then also he had
that game where against
um uh the other young play uh from
Germany whose name is thank you you had
that horrible opening didn't he um just
the other day which he which he ended up
turning around so sort of fair and just
going back to the game I think
Anish has lost control a little bit
because he's blundered back the pawn you
know he we were talking about the pieces
the organs being in good shape yep you
gotta watch out for those tactical
tricks and this trick was not really
disguised it was quite telegraphed if
anything let's jump in to show what
Anish giri missed uh black on the last
move brought his Rook across to attack
this backward Pawn that we've been
discussing and there's a few safe ways
to defend it uh for example you can drop
this Rook back to defend you can bring
your queen across to defend it
um maybe you could bring your Rook
across to block but uh plenty of options
this is not the best one uh the one
Anish chose he brought his Rook up but
this Rook is overloaded it's defending
this pawn and this white Rook can if a
piece is overloaded try to find a way to
take advantage of that and black simply
captured this Pawn because if the Rook
is taken now the other Rook Falls and uh
black in the process will have regained
the pawn he sacrificed earlier actually
with heavy interest suddenly the Knight
is attacked suddenly this Pawn is
attacked black is doing very very well
and Gary after this surprise after the
black Rook uh came down and captured
this Pawn he has to just recompose
himself and
play maybe a bit defensively suddenly
the white king is more open than the
black king there are ideas of checks
along the line checks on the diagonal
and uh it's all a bit loose for white
suddenly
yeah slipping the position is slipping
in erroneous favor and I don't know what
aronia's chances are of qualifying but I
feel he he needs to uh get a result here
at least maybe even a win to qualify so
this is the luck that aronian requires I
like this move though from a niche he's
at least centralizing his pieces but
look at the bar it's it's edging towards
Lev it's going that way for really the
first time
um looks still a bit strange to me
because White's pieces visually they're
under center of the board and
centralized pieces are is often great
yeah I guess the idea is that the Rook
check can at least now be blocked by
White's reckon
just like you Simon I don't really see
why it should be too bad for black uh
for white sorry it looks like everything
is under control everything's protected
suddenly the advantage is gone that's
for sure but
are you really worse with white with
such good pieces
I don't really think so since peculiar
doesn't have to say yeah so uh okay
small blunder there by Anish giri losing
his Advantage but still in the balance
and uh yeah you mentioned what Levon
needs so including this game there's
four games left in the prelims and if we
think that the magic number is around 21
22 points
he needs probably 10 points uh to have a
chance so 10 points out of four games
that's three wins and a draw
three and a half out of the last four
games I mean whatever happens we know
tomorrow is going to be it's always one
of the most exciting days
um of these events because you know half
the field go through half the field go
home and there's only a free game so
you've got to make sure you all come
along tomorrow for that I mean it's
going to be so fascinating might come
down to the last game decide who gets
kicked out we'll actually be um
in the final round two players who might
be uh really fighting to qualify yeah
and we'll find out who gets through to
those Knockouts there could be some very
juicy pairings yeah in The Knockout uh
stages
and uh okay black gave a check that was
blocked and now Black's Queen lining up
defending her Rooks
yeah suddenly the white king I'm just
trying to do some calculating here and
the Viking feels a bit vulnerable in a
few variations takes Knight a big threat
as well
if waiter just been lazy pushed a pawn
then uh Rook takes Knight is an option
just because White's piece is overloaded
or you can trade a set of Rooks and then
this Knight would have dropped off the
board uh the queen defending the Rook
black would emerge with extra Bishop so
the Knight retreated
and uh I guess he wants to just drop it
back to the square because that's ideal
defensively it will shield the white
king in a few ways
and how does Levon continue his
initiative the momentum yeah if you can
get the Knight to that square it seems
like Anish has again stabilized
everything that night would be very very
nicely Placer and uh Black's Bishop is
is not a good piece at the moment so
um white could be taken the advantage
again so this is the moment when Leslie
you've got to keep the pressure up or
reroute that Bishop but re-route the
bishop seems very dangerous at the
moment
um so look for ways to create Frets
going back to what you mentioned earlier
and there we go moving The Rook to
create a threat try to keep this mini
initiative going uh from the black side
and if white doesn't want to go or Pawn
down and lose this Pawn then he has to
retreat his Queen to this square but
suddenly at least there are some checks
on the diagonal so Brooke takes Knight
nearly working isn't it I mean uh very I
think it does work does it yeah I think
it might just stay tonight and suddenly
a queen check hitting the king only one
legal move and checkmate
Rook takes Knight look at her if it's
captured this ends in Checkmate check
and Checkmate that is incredible he's
blundered twice in this game a niche
twice within the space of four moves
completely collapsed right I mean he had
a great position porno blundered a pawn
now he's blundered a piece and uh this
is the luck that loves these Lev needed
some some boost like this to give him a
chance to qualify chess gods are shining
on Lev as they often do they're shown on
a niche in the last round with that
Checkmate and now they shine on Iranian
yeah wow Rook takes Knight this is
exactly what we're talking about earlier
CCT checks there aren't any checks
captures yes please there's a knight on
the edge of the board and yeah I missed
this one I've got to admit I was looking
at the other capture first but why not
capture a knight and this king is open
to open will it survive
yeah I think Niche is just getting ready
to resign it was a bit depressing
resigning such a game because you you
should never lose such a game and uh
you've got to mentally sort of prepare
yourself to
press that resign button haven't you
because I mean there's no way you can
play this the Queen's ready to dive in
you know Black's actually attacking with
the extra piece
um so there's there's just nothing here
at all that that can has any chance I
mean Black's threatening Checkmate in
two moves the White Queen can come in on
the diagonal in front of that black Rook
if you can imagine that checking the
king uh so it's completely over now
completely over there we go and he
shakes his head and clicks that resign
button wow
some dramatic endings for Anish giri in
the last few games he uh won in the
previous round with a Checkmate in the
last move and he loses this one after a
blunder both players looking over this
obviously live on aronian
he must be feeling very happy he is now
up to 14 points only two points behind
Anish giri we know he really needed a
win and this one